[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista Soy Jorge
Hurtado recientemente el fondo monetario
internacional advirtió que al menos un
tercio de las economías del mundo
entrarán el año que viene en recesión
técnica es decir tendrán al menos dos
trimestres consecutivos de contracción
de su producto interno bruto mientras
que para América Latina el organismo
prevé que la región enfrenta el impacto
del endurecimiento de las condiciones
monetarias mundiales sumado a la guerra
en Ucrania y los efectos de la pandemia
para conocer las perspectivas económicas
conversamos con Ilan golfman el ex
director para el hemisferio occidental
del fondo monetario internacional y bien
bienvenido un placer tenerlo aquí en
Francia 24
muy bien Buenas tardes
Ilan cómo describiría las perspectivas
de América Latina con relación al resto
del mundo la región crecerá
pues
2022 han subido en casi 1% a más de lo
que teníamos en abril que fue la última
proyección y la región debe ejercer
América Latina y el Caribe
3.5% que es como 1% a más también del
producto potencial pero
el mundo se va a desacelerar o sea china
Estados Unidos Europa Y eso significa
que la región también bajese menos en
este caso tenemos un crecimiento
promedio de
1.7%. casi la mitad de este año
y le pregunto cómo explicaríamos en
término el término recesión al ciudadano
de a pie Y cómo esta recesión podría
afectarlo
va a tener más dificultades y algunos
van a tener que pedir su empleo porque
no hay tantas oportunidades como como
teníamos antes eso pasa en momentos a
donde hay momentos de ajuste en la
economía Qué es lo que creo que va a
pasar el próximo año no queremos que
vamos a tener un ejercicio negativo Pero
vamos a tener una desaceleración que la
diferencia es que no se quedan tantos
empleos como anti las recesiones cuando
los empleos empiezan a pegarse la gente
Empieza a pedir sus empleos o sea una
recesión técnica es un pbi negativo en
dos trimestres le pregunto ahora cuál es
son los efectos del encarecimiento del
costo del endeudamiento para América
Latina esta famosa subida de las tasas
de interés Cómo afecta realmente a las
empresas y a los gobiernos de nuestra
y las personas tienen que pagar un tasa
interés mayor eso significa que le queda
mucho más caro a la gente que necesita
de préstamos también es posible que
muchas empresas cuando salen al mercado
internacional que no tengan el
financiamiento que necesitan no
solamente es caro Pero puede ser más
escaso o sea puede no existir tanta
disponibilidad con el pasado y eso pasa
en estos momentos a donde las tasas de
interés empiezan a subir Y eso hace que
todo se quede más caro
en América Latina los bancos centrales
también están apostando precisamente a
subir las tasas de interés Cómo afecta
esto a los ciudadanos
bueno de un lado
pasa que la actividad o sea el
crecimiento bajo un poco la creación de
empleo baja pero por el otro lado
vayan de tener un encrecimiento de
los precios de sus productos que tienen
entonces la inflación
empieza a bajar Y eso es muy importante
para que sus ventas real o sea cuánto
vale el salario Cuánto vale
la renta Cuánto puedo comprar eso va a
empezar a mejorar si el efecto de los
bancos centrales que suben las interés
que empiezan a bajar la inflación Si eso
ocurre Y eso lo que tenemos nosotros
proyectado que va a bajar el año que
viene y después va a llegar a su a su
meta en 2024 Si eso pasa
los consumidores les va a pasar que van
a tener unas condiciones mejores de lo
que ha pasado este año que en el momento
de inflación y precisamente de eso le
quiero preguntar este encarecimiento del
dinero Busca contener precisamente la
inflación en qué momento nos preguntamos
se comenzarán a ver los efectos
Bueno ya estamos viendo que las
economías que estaban muy muy calientes
ahora están un poco menos y ya se
empiezan a
demandar y a gastar menos en los últimos
meses creo que en el próximo 6 a 12
meses lo vamos a sentir con mucho más
intensidad
siendo América Latina un gran productor
de materias primas le pregunto cómo se
ha beneficiado del alza de los precios
de los commodities
cuando la alza de los precios significa
que los productos que estos países están
exportando
generan más dólares generan más
agradación y eso es bueno para el
balance de pagos tienes más dinero
tienes más reservas puedes importar más
y además tiene un impacto en la economía
que que la economía se queda con mucho
más capacidad de consumir de invertir en
ese momento Entonces lo que llamamos
nosotros el un
shock de términos de intercambio
positivo y eso es lo que pasó a los que
venden las comodis las comodines la
pueden meter a un precio mayor eso al
final beneficia de todo toda la economía
y la en la mayoría de economistas prevén
un panorama de recesión económica para
los próximos meses inclusive para el
próximo año le pregunto Cuáles son los
países que usted considera serían los
los más resilientes en América Latina y
también Cuáles van a ser los más
afectados Y por qué
nosotros vimos que los países que tienen
más reservas que tienen bajos centrales
más independientes y que tienen menos
gastos O sea la necesidad de
financiamiento menor y también son los
países que tienen
una deuda en moneda extranjea menor son
los países que van a poder tener más
resiliencia vas a ponerte más más
fuertes
enfrentando a los al shock externo que
vamos a pasar hemos visto el
fortalecimiento del dólar por varios
factores que ha generado la caída de las
monedas en algunas economías de América
Latina que se prevén términos de tasa de
cambio Podemos esperar que las monedas
sigan evaluándose
No porque no se sabe a principio tenemos
que ver cómo se juntan esas variables y
y y y muchos países que a veces piensas
que son más vulnerables no lo son y
algunos toman medidas políticas Fiscales
y monetarias que los ayuda a tener
digamos la la resiliencia
Cuáles serían las recomendaciones
puntuales del fondo monetario
internacional para que las decisiones
Fiscales de los gobiernos de la región
no estén politizadas
nosotros comentamos sobre las cosas
políticas lo que se tiene que hacer es
generar instituciones fuertes
instituciones que puedan
resistir a choques vamos centrales que
hacen su papel autónomo reglas Fiscales
que son buenas
El Ejecutivo haciendo sus papeles
legislativo haciendo el leer el sistema
judicial o sea las instituciones las
reglas funcionan eso es lo que es más
importante el fondo monetario
internacional se ha mostrado de acuerdo
con los impuestos a las grandes fortunas
sobre todo en tiempos de crisis por qué
lo más importante es que tengamos
capacidad de recaudar más en países que
tienen la declaración baja para poder
tener
los servicios públicos adecuados a las
poblaciones entonces en muchos países
los recursos que se tiene son muy bajos
comparados a los países del mundo en
estos países te necesita recaudar más
para poder tener mejores bienes públicos
y hay varias formas de hacerlo y un
sistema más progresivo o sea un sistema
que protege que tiene protección a los
va vulnerables es mejor en términos
equitativos pero también tenemos de la
pobreza señor Ilan goldman director para
el hemisferio occidental del fondo
monetario internacional Muchísimas
gracias por haber estado en France 24 un
agradecimiento especial a Juan Pablo
lucumi Daniela Blandón y Alba Santana
del equipo de economía por sus aportes
en la producción de esta emisión a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía recuerde
si quiere otro punto de vista que desde
aquí en Francia 24
[Música]